metro officers from the bolton area
command swarmed liberty baptist church
this morning but it wasn't for an
emergency
the call went far beyond that to prevent
crime from happening in the first place
hector mejia joins us live near lake
mead and rainbow to explain hi hector
hey there usually when you see a cluster
of cop cars you automatically think
something bad happened and you start to
worry
this time was different though officers
went straight into the kitchen
and made pancakes for people to enjoy
the event pastors police and pancakes
brought a few dozen people from
different denominations out to liberty
baptist church this morning
it's the first time such a large group
of pastors and metro police officers
were able to reconnect
during the pandemic the efforts go back
several years though as part of the
police department's recap program
rebuilding every city around peace the
goal has been to prevent violence and
reduce tensions in the community we're
told it's proven to be successful
we've seen lives changed we've seen
hungry kids find
help we've seen kids who need shoes fine
shoes we've seen kids who are
academically struggling find peer
counselors or mentors
an event like this it warms your heart
makes you feel good inside when you have
people that come out
and support you and support the efforts
and they want to come around you to
reduce the violence
a few years after this program was
launched in this community alone
violent crime dropped 75 percent that
was between 2013
and 2014 calls for service also dropped
27 percent
the bouldin area command covers 17.3
square miles and according to captain
carlos hank
right now communities all across the u.s
are craving peace
especially after everything we've been
dealing with over the last year
hector mejia reporting 8 news now